Yo! I hope you got your coffee ready
because this is another video request
for you guys! Some of you asked and said
hey Daniel what is the best supplements
for hair growth and thickness? So that's
what I'm gonna talk about in this video
let's not waste any more time. Let's get
right to it.
So good! Hey guys welcome
here on my channel! If this is the first
time you're here I'm Daniel.
Subscribe & click the notification bell so
you won't miss any of the next videos
Alright so let's start with the first
supplement for hair growth and thickness
Biotin from Solgar. Biotin
is a vitamin b-complex and so it
strengthens the protein infrastructure
of your hair, your nails, and your skin
Now this basic protein infrastructure is
called carotene. So I would suggest you
get the super high potency biotin from
Solgar and as always I'll add the
links of all the products for you in the
video description so you can go ahead
and check it out yourself so it's just a bit
easier. Also, check out the customer
reviews of people that tried it out
before. Alright let's move onto the next
one
Flaxseed oil from Nature made. Why?
Because flaxseed they have omega-3
fatty acids which help your hair
follicles to stay healthy and retain
water and produce sebum. It's got over
400 of happy customer reviews on Amazon
check it out in the video description
Folic acid from Nature Made. Now folic
acid
well aka B9 helps tissue regrowth and
circulation which helps your hair
follicles to function properly
Vitamin A and C. Why? Well both of them
helps your body to produce sebun which
is the natural oil that protects your
hair and keeps it strong
Zinc from Garden Of Life. Now Zinc is
very important for your hair. Why?
Because if your body... if you don't have enough zinc you can actually lose hair so zinc
is important for maintaining scalp
health through cell reproduction tissue
growth and repair. Now just some last
advice: Although some of these
supplements might work and will help you
out with your hair growth and the
thickness. The most important thing is
nutrition. If you have a poor nutrition
it's not just gonna show in your hair
but in your overall appearance as well
Now if you struggle with hair loss I've
added a few extra products for in the
video description that will definitely
help you out.
if you like the video give a thumbs up
Subscribe and I'll see you
in the next video
Cheers!